crawling out of the rubble of mariopol's
as of style steel plant and finally on
their way to safety
these people have been sheltering in
bunkers and tunnels underneath the
complex as it came under continuous
bombardment by russian forces
we've been waiting here for two months
they tell how they were running out of
food
children always wanted to eat you know
adults can wait
the man filming this video released by
ukraine's azov battalion says they're
trying to get people out while the
russians aren't shooting the evacuation
was part of what the united nations
called a safe passage operation during a
temporary ceasefire agreed by russia and
ukraine
today finally we managed to start the
evacuation of the people from as of
style after many weeks of negotiations
and many different meetings people calls
countries proposals finally
there was not a single day that we
didn't try to find a solution to ensure
the safe rescue of those people
up to a thousand civilians and two
thousand ukrainian fighters are believed
to have ended up inside the plant
surrounded by russian forces in the last
ukrainian-held territory in the port
city
people who were evacuated spoke of the
terror they experienced and of having to
live in darkness for more than 60 days
when the shell started landing at
avistal i thought my heart would stop
and i would not survive it
a ukrainian commander still in the
bunker says there's not enough water and
the air smells of decomposing bodies
i hope the evacuations will continue i
hope our government and the third party
the u.n mission the red cross will all
try to evacuate all civilians not only
from the plant but for mario paul in
general i also hope to evacuate all the
injured and killed to evacuate all
soldiers who are here now
some of those evacuated went to the
russian-held village of bezeymann others
headed to ukrainian territory in the
city of zaparisia
maripo authorities say a hundred
thousand people remain and what's left
of the city with hundreds more below
ground at the steelworks a factory
that's become a symbol of ukrainian
resistance alexia o'brien al jazeera